[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
it's January 6th
two year anniversary
[Music]
Cheeto dust kangaroo 2 attempt
and day four
of Kevin McCarthy still losing
that looks like that's what's going to
happen today there's supposedly a deal
I don't know how much of a deal it is
sounds like
um they have reached an agreement to
make Kevin McCarthy the speaker the
problem is
the problem is that they have three
members that are gone today the
Republicans that is they have three
members gone today here is the um the
scene from the
house chamber
as we look as they just did the Pledge
of Allegiance
and they're going to start to establish
a quorum here
so that way they can get to business the
only business
that the house Quorum can get to
is to a adjourn or B vote for a speaker
uh but
I don't believe
they will be able to
get past the threshold as Democrats hold
the 212. Kevin McCarthy there's Kevin
McCarthy look look at the loser look at
that [ __ ] loser
you gotta hand it to the guy
he really has taken quite the beating
I mean
there's not many people that would lose
this many times and come out on top as a
winner
but he's gonna keep voting we won't have
a congress we won't have a government
until he wins I guess I'm getting
frankly I'm getting sick and tired of it
I mean
I almost think that maybe we just go two
years where they just they just vote
for speaker every day
that's the only thing that they
accomplish
and they can't even get that done
uh yesterday there was talk that Ralph
Norman
who is a quackadoo by the way Ralph
Norman I think is from South Carolina or
North Carolina I'm not really sure uh
he's a he's a house rep he's a q anoner
full-on q and honor he believes that
Barack Obama and Eric Holder somehow the
shadow government or some dumb [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] these morons get elected
to congress is beyond me
they live in the same [ __ ] town
as the white out I mean they're they're
in Washington
and there's there's members of Congress
who still believe that Obama is somehow
running the government
it's like a shadow president or some
dumb [ __ ]
this is really stupid stuff
but these are the people that are making
deals with think about that for a second
think about this just put this in
perspective
Kevin McCarthy wants to be Speaker of
the House
it's the only thing he can see really at
this point I have to be speaker
and they're gonna go make deals
with members of Congress
who think Joe Biden isn't actually the
President Barack Obama a cabal a cabal
now I'm not [ __ ] I'm going to show
you these clips today
of Ralph Norman this this is who they're
doing deals with
Now Kevin McCarthy's gonna have to give
his entire speakership away apparently
he's made a deal with chip Roy to be I
think chip Roy wants to be the committee
chair on the rules committee
uh as we discussed before on this show
I hear this last week really that's the
one thing the speaker has
to operate business on the floor of the
house is the rules
and the rules committee
so
if you give the rules committee
away to a bunch of extremists
you're going to have a bunch of Extreme
Rules now this is the stupid tightrope
that Kevin McCarthy's trying to walk
here
he's trying to appease the crazy q and
honors you know the ones two years ago
as of today who were trying to make sure
to overthrow our government
who are helping the Cheeto dust q and
honor
and his attempt of the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
well
Kevin McCarthy is giving away his
speakership
to those knuckleheads
that's the deal he's gonna have to make
now
also on the Democratic side we have uh
Democrats staying at 212 for Hakeem
Jeffries they're not going to break that
vote
even even Matt gatz last night said on
Fox news that he would resign
his house seat
if Democrats formed a coalition around a
moderate Republican
I actually believe that Democrats are
not going to form a coalition around a
moderate Republican I I believe
Matt gatz when he said that because
yesterday when I was on the Midas touch
Network's coverage after the show
uh we watched as Getz was walking around
the floor talking to many Democrats
and talking to many Republicans because
he's trying to figure out what deal is
going to be made because they don't want
Kevin McCarthy to be the Speaker of the
House let's go to the house floor let's
see um
what they're going to be doing here
the question
the election of speaker the tellers will
please come forward and take their seats
so we're going to be getting to a
a vote for speaker here I guess
apparently they're not going to vote to
adjourn uh now if there is a deal with
chip Roy right I don't know if you guys
know who chip Roy is he's um he's again
he's a [ __ ] Q anoner from Texas he's
an insurrectionist and these these
people are all one and the same these
Republicans
this is not surprising I mean yesterday
you watched as as Marjorie Taylor green
and George Santos flirted on the floor
of the house I don't know if they were
planning on having a dinner date or what
but
apparently they were
they were talking and flirting there
anyways
they're all one in the same these
Republicans
and this is why I told you for an entire
year you need to go vote you need to
engage in your democracy
he's [ __ ] boneheads are going to take
over your government and it's not going
to be good I mean Jesus Christ we're in
day four
day four
of these boneheads trying to find a
speaker and they haven't moved an inch
haven't moved an inch
now yesterday
um Matt Getz did vote
as the other column for Donald Trump and
then he nominated it uh here we go
here's uh some more on the house floor
they're going to nominate Kevin McCarthy
again
oh
I wonder if he's gonna lose again
the gentleman is recognized
and while I Rise to that end I think
it's critically important to note that
this is actually not about Kevin
McCarthy
Kevin is a good man he's a man of God
he's a patriot he's a leader who has led
this conference to our current majority
over the last four years those things
are unassailable
but this isn't about him
this isn't about Kevin McCarthy
I put no single human being on a
pedestal and certainly not before God
and not before the gift that he has
blessed us with with this Grand
experiment that we call the United
States of America
this isn't about Kevin McCarthy
but the matters before us are of
stupendous magnitude
a federal republic such as ours it's
it's a dynamically unstable one it's a
wobbly top that's just a few mere
revolutions away from falling down at
any given moment
except for the exertions of men and
women who are willing to serve her with
pure and selfless intent just as our
founding fathers did just as Abraham
Lincoln and Ronald Reagan did with pure
and selfless intent
and as our nation today and over the
last two years has seen we are certainly
a wobbly top
today we have a southern border that is
wide open as a result of that and as a
result of our executive branch policies
today 200 fellow Americans will die of
fentanyl poisoning and roughly 5 000
illegal immigrants will be victims of
human smuggling
today our nation's debt is 31 trillion
dollars and that will go up just in this
day alone by roughly 2.1 billion dollars
today we are seeing one of the worst
crime spikes in our nation's history our
law enforcement are directly underfunded
and they are hurting
and on that topic I want to thank our
law enforcement I want to especially
thank the Capitol Hill Police for what
they do we thank them not only for what
they've done
thank you
[Applause]
so here they are um clapping the law
enforcement officers
but I guess the law enforcement officers
that was killed when they when they
stoked a violent Insurrection on January
6th [ __ ] those [ __ ] those police uh we
don't back those blue we don't give a
[ __ ] about them we don't care about the
police officers that protect the capitol
on January 6th got their asses kicked
some of them killed
companies
and the Chinese Communist party is still
today not being held accountable for the
deaths of millions of people around this
planet deaths as a result of a genocide
within their borders and deaths as a
result of covid outside them
we are today losing on multiple fronts
against China
so today isn't about a single human
being it's not about Kevin McCarthy it's
about the 13 gold star families who
still suffer today mercifully without
closure and without accountability after
the unnecessary loss of their loved ones
in Afghanistan over a year ago
and today speaking of our military today
roughly 40 active duty and Veterans of
our military will commit suicide these
Madam clerk these are the matters of
stupendous magnitude this isn't about a
a man in a suit in the halls of Congress
it's about 330 million Americans it's
about the preservation of the
Constitution and the Liberties
guaranteed therein
it's about the 246 years of Pride and
Providence that we have enjoyed as a
nation
and above all things
it's about ensuring that this beautiful
Journey exists for generations to come
that doesn't happen if we don't address
and rise above the multiple existential
crises that we experience today we must
be victorious in this cause and victory
begins with allowing this body to get to
work it begins today
now winning isn't easy
okay winning isn't easy but winning is
necessary and of all folks in this
chamber I know that that winning isn't
easy I represent a district
where only 29 of my voters are
registered as in the same party as I
but I engage and I communicate with the
other 71 percent because it's the only
way that we all win and in the end it's
the only way that the nation wins
it ain't easy but it's necessary but the
noble wins the most important wins never
are easy
but we take on these missions just as
passionately as Colonel Chamberlain did
at Little Round Top in Gettysburg
we must hold this line because if we
don't hold this line the entire Union is
at stake
we don't hold the majority for Brown
okay I've had enough of this Mike Garcia
Mike Garcia California
the hell out of here with this nonsense
he keeps he keeps uh acting like their
party wants democracy
he keeps talking like their party
loves the union loves the Constitution
two years ago
today
the former president of the United
States
and his allies stood on stage members of
Congress even Mo Brooks with a flak
jacket on
incited a violent insurrection
on the same chamber that they're
standing in
and here to overthrow our vote
to take away our constitution what in
the [ __ ] do these dummies think would
happen
on January 6 2021
if Donald Trump and his cohort a
nincomputin Nazis would have been
successful
in the violent Insurrection on the
capitol
and overthrowing our constitution
what do you think would have happened to
our constitution you think Donald Trump
would be like oh yeah well that
Constitution that's a great thing
I mean I just tore it to shreds and
wiped my ass with it but that
Constitution is a great thing
these are not serious people
the Republican Party
is so far down the Q Anon rabbit hole
that they have no idea what it takes
to govern
in our democracy and I've said this this
last week
this is
a beautiful display of how our democracy
works
not only is it a beautiful display of
how our democracy works
it is the exact reason why you the
protomoc part of the pro-democracy
coalition
should continue
to engage in your democracy
and lean into it
now is not the time
to step away and take a break no now is
the time
to continue to mock
and to continue to hold these
Republicans to account
so Mark Mark Garcia of California here
nominating Kevin McCarthy with all the
same old lies and tropes that
Republicans have
is fitting
it's fitting because this is why Kevin
McCarthy is not speaker yet
we have not seen this many votes for
speaker
and almost 200 years
here's Jim Clyburn let's listen to Jim
clyber Jeffries a speaker the gentleman
is recognized
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Madam cleric
I don't want to begin by thanking you
for your contribution to maintaining the
dignity and honor of this August body
the eyes of the country
[Applause]
the eyes of the country are on us today
let us consider
what they will remember
I often refer to this Hall
as America's classroom
the proceedings to be undertake in this
body
and our actions to serve as lessons for
those who may be watching
and or listening
hopefully that which they see and hear
will help them gain understanding
and appreciation
for the greatness of America and the
goodness of the American people
this body
has a unique role
in this government
what we do
and how we do it
we'll determine whether our Pursuit
toward a more perfect union
can continue
in earnest
no day in recent history
underscores the importance of their
Pursuit more than January 6 20 21.
exactly two years ago today
our resolve was tested
when the Violet mob of interestedness
attacked our capital
threatened the Integrity of this
democracy and underline mind our
constitution
the greatness of this country
and the resiliency of our democracy were
put at General
but
we survived
the Preamble of the Constitution
explains
that the document was established in
part
to secure the blessings of liberty
not just for ourselves
but also
to posterity
in this party
real tasked with protecting our nation's
hard-earned principles of Liberty
Justice and freedom for all
every two years
the American people evaluate our
stewardship
and render a verdict
last November
they invested their time and resources
going to the polls
and casting their votes
they expect
and should get it just returned on their
Investments
for a minute
maybe most Americans this is the only
investment they will ever make
to help preserve the greatness of this
country
for the first time
in over 200 years
after 11 rounds of voting
we are unable
to organize
and begin to work
on behalf of those who elected us to
serve
Democrats are offering a candidate for
speaker Hakeem Jeffress
was not just prepared to lead
but committed to preserve in this
democracy
and enhancing this August body
Madam Clerk
there is some dispute
among historians
as to whether Alexis de tocqueville said
this
but I consider it to be true
regardless
the talk field is credited
in some quarters with having said
America is great
because she is good
if America ceases to be good
America
will cease to be great
the greatness of America
lies in the goodness that exists within
the American people
today
the greatness of our nation
hangs in the balance because the
goodness of the American people
is at stake
we Democrats
are offering the people of America
through this unique body
a good man
who has the best interest of the
American people at heart and is
committed
to preserving the fundamental principles
that make this country great
Madam cleric I'm honored
to carry out
the directives or the house Democratic
caucus
and submit
to this August body
the name of Hakeem Jeffress to be
speaker of the United States House of
Representatives
there you have it Jim Clyburn
nominating Akeem Japanese again
as the Democratic nominee for Speaker of
the House of course we all know that the
man on the screen there Hakeem Jeffries
would absolutely run [ __ ] democracy
circles around any Republican that would
be nominated or be Speaker of the House
well if you watch the king Jeffrey speak
but the man is on point with messaging
and narrative
he understands the American political
body more than
almost any other Democrat here's Matt
gatz going to uh nominate Trump probably
Mr Speaker here we go
Garcia knows the incredibly high regard
I hold him in he is a patriot I deeply
deeply admire him but I must take some
exception with some of the comments he
made in his nomination of Mr McCarthy
first he said that Mr McCarthy has
earned the position
you only earn the position of speaker of
the house if you can get the votes Mr
McCarthy doesn't have the votes today he
will not have the votes tomorrow and he
will not have the votes next week next
month next year and so one must Wonder
Madam clerk is this an exercise in
vanity for someone who has done the math
taken the counts and is putting this
institution through something okay get
on with it [ __ ] stick is avoidable get
on with it get on with it who are you
nominating Mr Garcia did not say this
but many of my other Republican
colleagues have they believe that Mr
McCarthy has earned the position of
speaker of the house because he raised
half a billion dollars to get
Republicans elected
uh there's a little scuffle on the floor
here I'm not sure exactly who the person
is
members are reminded not to engage in
personalities against other members of
the House
several believe that one earns the
position of speakers
they can't do it they can't do it okay I
get individuals
they can't do it they can't do it I'm
not really sure who stood up uh people
are asking who stood up I'm not really
sure
uh who's the one who stood up and
started yelling and screaming we'll
probably find out uh soon uh let's uh
let's check Twitter see if we can see
let's listen to [ __ ] here while I
see if I can find out who's standing up
talking I heard my colleague from
California Mr Garcia say that we seek
pure selfless intent and I could not
agree more with that assessment Mr
Jordan indeed is reflective of pure
selfless intent
I don't know that the same can be said
for the Republican alternative let's
start with purity
many of you have seen the reports that
there are negotiations to determine
whether or not on this side of the aisle
there can be a deal a meaning of the
minds a grand bargain that would allow
us to proceed with the speakership and I
want all of my colleagues to know
regardless of your perspective on me how
impure some of those negotiations have
gone and I want the country to know
the principal goal of the people who are
objecting to Mr McCarthy on the
Republican side is that we don't believe
the rules of this place unlock the
potential of all of the members to be
able to cast votes on individual bills
and to offer amendments on
Appropriations acts and we're also
concerned about spending that has
ballooned our debt and borrowed against
the future generations of American
citizens and Mr McCarthy said well
goodness to the objectors okay okay okay
more [ __ ] lies from rapey mcforhead
here
listen
Matt Getz
the one the the
only party that has increased the
deficit and the debt more than any other
party is the [ __ ] Republicans
Republicans always destroy the economy
and Democrats have to come in and
[ __ ] save it we've seen that during
the pandemic we've seen that over the
last two years
and I I know I know it doesn't feel like
it but at this moment in time
this is good for our country to see just
how inept and how ineffective the
Republican party is and they're not even
really a party at this point
they're not even a [ __ ] party at this
point intense let's go back to Butthead
here
by personal ambition and that ambition
is paralyzing the house now
Madam clerk at this time there is great
trust in Mr Jordan and that's why I am
nominating him and there is uh
insufficient trust in Kevin McCarthy
members are leaving the floor
I don't know if you noticed that but
they were leaving the floor I don't know
I had a protest or if they're meeting
about a deal that would convert the
speakership from the great awesome
powerful position it is now to more of a
ceremonial position almost akin to the
speaker in the British House of Commons
oh God come on get on with it you [ __ ]
box
that some of us were trying to construct
just just nominate who you're going to
nominate for crying out loud
carthy with power because we know who he
will use it for and we are concerned it
will not be for the American people we
trust Jim Jordan I nominate him and I'm
going to vote for him
and there you go he's nominating Jim
Jordan
uh so Jim Jordan again
Jesus another idiot okay let's go back
to the idiot a woman is recognized
once again I just stand here today to
nominate Kevin Hearn the chairman of the
Republican study committee the largest
caucus in the Republican conference who
unanimously was elected as chairman whom
I believe can unite this okay Lauren
bonehead here is going to nominate Kevin
Hearn again so now we're gonna have
three Republicans on this ballot
they walked away from Byron Donald's
caught on to that
they don't think Byron Donald's will be
a good candidate inflation is hurting
your family
excuse me I got a bit of a cough today
I'm trying to mute when I have the cough
but attached to the floor we will try to
work the American people
the reading again this [ __ ] idiot
doesn't know how to yield back her time
I don't know if you caught that or not
she just like ah [ __ ] it and walks away
she doesn't even know the rules on the
floor
doesn't care about the rules doesn't
care about how you're supposed to have
regular order in the house
God damn
yeah again she did not yield back her
time at all she just said Thank you and
walked away it's probably intentional
I'm sure
because she has no respect
absolutely none
Jeffries uh so here we're going to go to
the vote
uh
uh so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep this uh
going here but I do want to
um uh show you guys some video of
yesterday
um after the
vote yesterday and and maybe a deal that
was happening there's a rep name out
there Ralph Norman uh there's supposedly
a deal with old Ralph uh and I believe
Ralph Norman is from
Carolinas I'm not sure which one let me
see if I can pull up he's a [ __ ]
Cuban honor
yeah so here is Ralph Norman uh this is
from December 27th so this is from just
about a week ago oh man that's not what
I want to do let's do this there we go
now I gotta get the uh the actual
boo
there we go
so here is uh Ralph Norman
on Trader TV News Network real America's
voice
and this is what he has to say about
our government and how he is a Q and
honor I'm not [ __ ] you this is real
it'll subpoena as many people as we can
uh we're gonna hopefully have
consequences starting with mayorkas uh
Ray with the FBI I mean a whole host of
things the whole Administration is a
rogue Administration and I guess we all
know Joe Biden is not running this
country there is a cabal of unelected
elitists who are running this country
probably Barack Obama is involved
probably uh Eric Holder and but who
knows we know it's not Biden we're going
to subpoena as many people
there you have it Ralph Norman the Q
anoner now why is this significant
because yesterday they were trying to do
deals with this [ __ ]
they were trying to do deals
this is the person that they're
negotiating with folks
they're they are negotiating with this
person to set the rules of Our House of
Representatives
this guy doesn't even know Joe Biden is
the president of the United States
he thinks somehow Barack Obama and Eric
Holder is running the government or some
[ __ ] it really is
I can't even believe this is where we're
at but this is where we're at
Kevin McCarthy's doing deals with this
[ __ ]
um here is uh uh here we go
Rachel bidikoffer Dr Rachel bittickoffer
my friend a friend of the show she wrote
this this morning on Twitter
Republicans learning the hard lesson on
why you don't negotiate with terrorists
pretty simple right
I mean do you think they [ __ ] figure
this out by now
you can't negotiate with these [ __ ]
idiots
now the problem that they have here is
they have to
right this is why we told America
don't do this do not put Republicans in
charge of anything if you put them in
charge of something
they're going to destroy it
because that's what they do
they absolutely destroy
everything
uh here is let's see
I've got some video
of yesterday
and this is a
um a Kevin McCarthy supporter
representative uh Troy newells I believe
on CNN
here's this is more [ __ ] you cannot
listen
these are not [ __ ] serious people
okay they're just not and if you treat
them like they're serious people you are
not [ __ ] a serious person you're not
a serious [ __ ] journalist you're not
a serious [ __ ] pundit these people
are insane they're lunatics listen to
this nonsense
over on CNN these conversations so I'll
assume when you call me a young lady it
was a compliment of course it was this
is my first time on the Clinton News
Network absolutely
ah Jesus Christ
this is a member of Congress
okay now I I [ __ ] around here [ __ ] I'm
the goddamn rodeo clown
of the uh of the liberal of the liberal
coalition
but that's my job my job is to be a
clown my job is to be to to distract
the bull okay this guy's a member of
Congress
he's elected
an elected official goes on CNN and
calls it Clinton News Network it's
really [ __ ] dumb it just shows how
unserious these people are and to be
quite honest with you
if you treat them serious you are not a
serious person let's continue here okay
that that that I will say was a bit in
my opinion rude but I'm glad you're
talking to me and I will treat you with
the respect that you deserve ah see
what I mean if there's see if you treat
them
as serious people you
are not a serious person
sorry Burnette you're not you're just
you're just not you're you're just not
and I do want to show you a moment from
yesterday you know that Matt Getz um he
voted for Trump on uh the other ballot
and he also nominated Trump so we make
good on his promise that he would
nominate Trump
um
he made good on his promise to nominate
Trump now
the problem is Trump only got one vote
and it was it was Matt Getz
so uh but here's the moment here's the
moment yesterday on the house floor
of the State of Florida has received one
[Applause]
with one recorded
ah they laugh
because it's funny that's funny [ __ ]
it's funny [ __ ]
that the Cheeto dots q and honor
couldn't even conjure up a couple
[ __ ] votes
couldn't even get two
hmm uh Liam Neeson had this to say about
the picture of Marjorie Taylor Greene
and George Soros yesterday well
somebody's getting lucky tonight it's
sure as hell ain't sure as [ __ ] isn't
Kevin McCarthy here's um
Marjorie Teeter green
and George Santos
what do you think
ooh
there was several moments people have
been um memeing online
so we'll see with that relation where
that relationship goes ugh
so so there's I I tell you what C-SPAN
is normally [ __ ] boring as [ __ ] right
and C-SPAN is boring I there's no way
there's no way that you [ __ ] would
stay tuned into me
uh showing you C C-SPAN for four days
straight on a normal basis right there's
no way I could show C-SPAN and the pals
floor for four days straight and you
guys stay tuned in
but let me tell you the drama of the
Republicans absolutely not being able to
govern and form a government
and having a speaker holy [ __ ] there's
been some great moments
some absolutely great moments
um in in these last few days Let's uh
man I'm telling you I got um
I got a bit of a cough it's not I don't
know what it is you know what I mean
um so this is the anniversary of January
6. I don't want to go without talking
about that
um for a second uh January 6th
2021 we all know is a day that
um where Donald Trump and the president
and the United States at that time
um
tried to steal away our constitution
he incited a violent insurrection
he had many legs to the stool of the
Cheeto dust coup attempt
one of those being in the house chamber
with current members of the House
and also
members of the House who have become new
members of the House
it really is something that we're here
on January 6 two years after
the violent insurrection
and the party that tried to overthrow
our Constitution that tried to overthrow
our vote
can't seem to govern it's almost as if
they don't understand how our democracy
works it's almost if they don't
understand how governance works it's
almost if they don't want governance
it's almost like they don't want
democracy
but the Democrats
and true pro-democracy Style
are making sure
that the American people can hold these
boneheads accountable speaking of
boneheads
um did you get up this morning I did I
did
finally finally you know you got you
gotta watch in in your mouth yeah me too
I gotta loot it yeah well I I've been
eating glutens there's my empty package
nice yeah gluten's a cherry I thought by
now honestly I thought by now
um yeah well here here's a here's a real
question
I thought by now I would be done with
coven yeah but it seems to have a second
wind
oh really
well the the tests were slowly going in
a negative they were they were fading
fading fading then yesterday I sent you
the test and it was almost like a clear
line again and now now I have to ask
myself
now I have to ask myself
will I get rid of covet before Kevin
McCarthy can get the votes needed to
become speaker of the house yeah that's
funny yeah maybe um maybe you should try
to um put the two together how many
votes has he lost now 500 and what how
many oh we're at 11. his count is 547.
yeah they're um actually according to my
board according to my board
yeah I have o and 12 right now well he
he is that we are taking the 12th vote
right now yeah yeah no he's not gonna
win he's not gonna win any votes today
he's not gonna win any votes today well
he can't because there's three members
apparently right here's the thing go
back to there he can't win because
they've already thrown in another two
people
you know they threw Jim Jordan back in
then they Dr then they threw Hearn back
in he he will not have the votes
necessary
because they continue to fragment their
base
and I mean the question is like how long
can they do it you know Lauren bobert
said on the 11th Hour that she's willing
to go till the cherry blossoms come in
yesterday you I don't know dude it's
like every the other thing too is like
you hear these these people these these
uh terrorists I mean that's what they
call themselves they literally call
themselves that CPAC in August on the
weekend of August 4th 2022 they said we
are domestic terrorists they put it on
the big jumbo screen they said it
themselves they were trying to be ironic
but they were just being truthful
and now
you're seeing that right now you you
talked about it earlier it's like you
don't negotiate with terrorists there's
a reason why you don't do it because if
you give them an inch they're going to
take a mile and these people are you
know one day they're talking about the
Democrats being drunk just because they
brought popcorn in to watch their drama
unfold in real time you had people there
there's Matt Getz he just voted for Jim
Jordan which puts um right two for
Hearns two for Jordan and by my count I
believe that is uh the 12th vote for
Kevin McCarthy I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
calling it as I see it I'm Gonna Knock
this 12 out in a moment and I'm gonna
make it 13 because I'm just gonna
Advance it in my prediction I guess I
guess the the the question here really
is not not are we going to have a
speaker today because the answer to that
is no but the real question is how many
votes are Democrats going to force
Republicans to take I think that's the
question because Democrats are going to
keep put like it's a because here's the
thing Democrats are united they have not
shifted one way or another their message
is the same they they have they have uh
nominated the same person Hakeem Jeffers
again and again and again and again and
again and again and again and again and
again
and now when you really really look at
this it's showing Democrats are united
they have their [ __ ] together
and when you look at Republicans they're
the ones who have gone four days now
right this is the fourth day
they haven't gotten [ __ ] done
and they're going to continue to do this
whether it's their own infighting or
their own desire to own the libs or
they're so they have such tunnel vision
right now that they can't see the full
the full kind of like picture and that's
their problem they never future proof
their dumb ideas like the I did that
sticker where the gas prices going down
well no they're not even as ever good
but they're not even future proofing the
idea here that the entire Democratic
caucus is staying fast behind Hakeem
Jeffries like literally they run
straight into the point here is um this
is a oh yeah I know you're gonna play
it's a good clip now mechats guarantees
this is crazy that he knows this fact
and he says it out loud on Fox News and
they don't even realize the the future
ramifications of this because the future
ramifications of the entire Democratic
caucus
all 212 of them voting for Hakeem
Jeffries every single time until
Republicans get their [ __ ] together the
future ramifications of that is Hakeem
Jeffries will be the speaker of the
house yeah unanimously for the
Democratic caucus and next year in 2024
when we get down to the election that is
going to be one of the main key talking
points that Republic in this at this
moment where they couldn't select a
speaker
you couldn't even you couldn't even get
your [ __ ] together but Democrats stayed
strong here's here's Matt gatz saying he
would resign
if there was any break in Democratic
votes listen
no absolutely not that that will not
happen there are two people scenarios
here no that listen I'm on the floor
Laura these 212 Democrats are going to
vote for Hakeem Jeffries every single
time he is a historic candidate for them
they are not going to cleave off under
any circumstance I assure you that if
Democrats join up to elect a moderate
Republican I will resign from the House
of Representatives that is how certain I
am I can assure your viewers that won't
happen are you now now honestly it makes
me want them to do that
just so he'll resign of course he
wouldn't resign even if they did that
but he's right he's been running around
the house floor he's talking to AOC
talking to the squad talking uh to
several members on the Democratic side
yesterday when I was on the Midas touch
coverage of the 105th vote and the 129th
vote
um it feels like they it feels like
we're there really yeah
um that many votes but but as as the
floor was happening Matt gatz was
running around the floor and Matt gatz
and Lauren bobert seemed very upset
they're very pissed off about what was
happening
um and they couldn't seem to stay
focused and and it's because there's
deals being made
on the Republican side is what is
happening here uh we got word yesterday
Ralph Norman this Q Anon or this crazy
[ __ ] nutbox was um and they were they
were negotiating with him and then this
morning chip Roy apparently there's a
deal made with chip Roy for him to be
that rules committee chair Jesus Christ
well at the end of the day look there's
not going to be and Kevin McCarthy is
literally handing out all power to all
of these terrorists
so that he can get the nomination by the
time that he gets into office I wouldn't
be surprised if some Republican found
some [ __ ]
sub Clause part 47 part 35 like I can
tell you right now that somebody is
scheming in the background to negotiate
these rules and power so that when
McCarthy does come into power one of
them's gonna [ __ ] stab him in the
back and say ah I am now the new speaker
of the house like somebody has some
crazy out like crazy crazy Antiquated
law that somebody found in some crazy
Archive of the Library of Congress and
they're going to use it on McCarthy but
if they if and that's you know a joke
but also they're kind of a little bit of
seriousness that
because that shows you who they are but
outside of that by the time that
McCarthy gets the votes he's gonna have
no power it's just a title he will have
a gavel right it'll be a little stick
it'll drumming on the drumming on the
table but there's actual no power
because he's given everyone else
rule the Committees uh different
different groups like there's gonna be
nothing left that he can actually do in
control his party because because they
have control over him they're literally
cucking him in front of him
and making him watch as as the as his
nomination gets [ __ ]
well he is completely [ __ ] here
um regardless if he actually is able to
pull off this speaker ship or not uh he
is completely [ __ ] I I don't I don't
think
that Kevin McCarthy cares how much power
he has to give away at this point his
main goal is to be just speaker I had my
name on the speaker's office door
and I became speaker for a couple months
and that is all that matters to him he
there is nothing else that matters to
Kevin McCarthy any more than that and
really if um I mean Kevin McCarthy's day
as a congressman are are numbered here
oh and the reason why is because even if
he becomes a speaker and they remove him
as Speaker which they probably will soon
sooner rather than later he will resign
his seat from Congress
and if he does not win the speakership
if he doesn't win it and someone else
gets the speakership he will also have
to resign
um from Congress so now I I do want to
say
um that
and the audience did exactly what we
thought they would do with bonehead of
the week of course we're going to go to
bonehead here yeah very soon
um but Kevin ended up being on the
bonehead of the week so uh and I don't
want to give away everything here but
it's pretty obvious it's pretty obvious
who um who's gonna win this
um but we also had uh uh let's see we
had who else do oh Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert can you find me some
of the memes of uh Marjorie Taylor green
and George Santos some of the best ones
oh yeah because this moment yesterday
where they were sitting next to each
other gabbing yeah and they're just
they're just like I don't know it's it's
just funny that Marjorie Taylor green
because uh I think it was last week and
I showed the Tweet she was tweeting like
oh George Santos isn't that much of a
liar look at the Democrats lies and like
ever since then they just piled on and
piled on and piled on but she was one of
the only ones that would actually go
talk to him and she sat next to him
yesterday for several uh minutes and I
was telling the audience earlier I'm
like you know we couldn't normally show
C-SPAN coverage on our show for like
four days straight like we would lose
the entire audience like why are you
still showing it's but this last four
days has been some great [ __ ] some
great honestly dude the 2023 season of
C-SPAN has been lit uh and I think I
tweeted that the other day like on day
two uh I think day two of this whole
drama thing I was like dude this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] lit this [ __ ] is awesome because
no other time yesterday I almost wanted
to tweet I'd be like I don't know why
C-SPAN isn't selling ad space at this
point like I know that C-SPAN is a
government-funded
um
asset right in in in in what they offer
but like uh pretty sure the government
could make money right now if they were
running ad space
now who would sell ads on it I don't
know I'm sure Mike Lindell would love to
sell some my pillow [ __ ] but when you
look at it promo code dumb [ __ ] right
exactly it's uh
so here's one of the pictures
and you the link you sent me of uh why
are you she's having a great time with
Santos oh a grand old time now look at
her she's so excited yeah and Jim Jordan
is in this picture too which makes it
even and he's kind of looking off he's
not really paying attention to the
problem you know like he would normally
dude Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
um
he's looking away from the problem he
doesn't really want to know the problem
if you get my drift here but um Indie
Refugee says George Santos points out
his skinny Jewish
space laser to Q Anon follower Marjorie
green
as a jealous Jim Jordan looks on
I mean you just can't make this [ __ ] up
right I mean it seems to be there there
seems to be a theme with uh
here's another one
there's some good memes out there this
yeah I'm trying to find them all I mean
like there's a bunch of people who are
just like commenting on it but then
there's other people who are like you
know adding some context here's um
here's another one they they've been
buddy buddy
this is this is crazy
well you know birds like a feather
right our space Jewish space lasers of a
Feather I guess again a liar and a liar
get along I wonder you know there's been
a lot of speculation of Marjorie Taylor
green uh having affairs with folks
around Washington I wonder I just wonder
if she's
taken to George Santos maybe she thinks
maybe she looks at George Santos you
know how there's like the idea of like
um
you know like a woman's like oh I I feel
like I can fix him right there's that
whole like right you know train him
train him kind of right right right so
in this context I wonder if she looks at
and she's like oh you know what he's gay
but I could make him straight or like
I've always wanted a gay best friend or
I mean this again assuming that he is
gay we don't know like he was straight
he was gay like whatever he is that's
fine but the guy is a fraud so we don't
really know who he is or what he is I
mean like well we witnessed we witnessed
he didn't even really know his name if
that really is his name right one and it
happened again yesterday I I can you
pull those moments can you see if you
can find those because they call his
name and it takes several times for him
to realize oh that's my fake name I I
need to it really was it it was almost
like a Bueller moment you know well
here's here's a great meme that's of
course you see Marjorie Taylor green uh
Whispering sweet nothings into George
Santos here and he's this guy is so so
desperate to feel accepted right now
because he hasn't been sworn in so he's
not an actual member of Congress well
none of these people are nonetheless
people which is kind of crazy to think
about that the people who aren't sworn
in who aren't officially members of
Congress can vote on someone who then
would be the leader of Congress you know
it's kind of weird but whatever what
it's so this one says and then I said to
Kevin when the FBI comes for me I'll
just say that George Santos said he left
the pipe bombs because uh I don't know
do you remember do you recall this I
think last week the FBI has increased uh
the uh the amount of reward for
information for the pipe bomber I
believe it's up to five hundred thousand
dollars now for any information leading
to Marjorie Taylor I mean I'll submit
her name as many times as I need to
I mean I'm just saying I I feel like at
some point
someone's gonna have to take me
seriously and look into it whether they
inspect the gate which is the the way in
which you know you walk or or what but
at some point someone's got to take it
seriously and say oh yes in fact it was
Martha Taylor green she is the one that
dropped the old
uh near the capitol she's the pipe
bomber yeah so here is um here's one of
the moments where George Santos if that
is his name yeah didn't recall his name
during the vote count here it is Santos
Santos
sarpines missed it he missed it name
name got called twice on his phone
chatting with this other dick over here
and then they go sarbane and then he's
like oh oh oh oh
uh uh uh uh uh what's the guy's name
what's the guy's name I'm supposed to
vote for he's like uh uh uh yeah it's it
honestly
these these idiots I mean like on their
their incompetent uh domestic terrorists
uh they're Republicans sympathizer
they're Republicans
Under the Umbrella of Republicans inside
you've got Nazi sympathizers you've got
a q Anon you know Believers you've got
human traffickers you've got groomers
you've got Liars thieves griffs I mean
the batch of people that are awful
humans
are just
so big the party is so big you've got
people that are making dumb CNN jokes
and being misogynistic on interviews I
think you played that clip earlier of
CNN like yeah
they're not serious people young lady
they don't take their job seriously but
that's the problem if the media has is
that if if if you if you act like these
are serious people you are not a serious
person because she went on to say oh
well that's I'm that's kind of offensive
or whatever she should have said what
the [ __ ] did you just say you're a
member of Congress you were on a
national TV Cable News Network to have a
serious conversation with me about how
you are going to form our government
right you remember to vote to to secure
the 118th Congress to pick a speaker to
move forward for the American people and
you're standing here making jokes about
the name and the network that you're on
that's that is how it needs to be
approached
they need to stop treating these people
like they're [ __ ] serious people
right they're just not they're not I
just say I sent you another link I don't
know if you saw this yeah but of course
this happened
is
a Herschel Walker staff member was
groped by Matt schlapp
what
no I did this last night look you know I
mean how much how much [ __ ] how much
[ __ ] news can we yeah man it's like
well it unsup this is this is also not
surprising right so again when it comes
to Herschel Walker wait a second wait a
minute again wait a second wait a second
I just want to make sure I'm clear
because this headline is a bit deceiving
Herschel Walker staffer now this is a
quote apparently match slap if you guys
don't know who Matt Slap is he's the
leader of CPAC he's the guy who
organized him and his wife do it groped
my crotch now
is this like a [ __ ] grabbing thing or
is he grabbing you know
um nuts and sausage I just want to make
sure I'm clear was he checking someone's
gender because these Republicans like to
do that they they do they do but it was
a it was a it was a nuts and sausage
situation
I would not be surprised uh by that by
that uh story that I mean a lot of these
people you know a lot of these people
they're they project their own
their own wants and desires and again
like there's nothing wrong with whatever
your sexuality I miss this how the [ __ ]
did I mean it happened it happened
yesterday at uh
let's see what time was originally
updated it was so it happened like in
the afternoon early afternoon here's
um the Tweet about it
um from esqueer
um once again the closet cases of the
ones who consistently do the most damage
to the lgbtq people match slap runs the
American conservative Union which puts
together CPAC which is consistently
platform the most bigoted anti-lgbtq
figures in the U.S and here he is
groping another man which I mean hey I
I'm all hey I don't care what match Labs
sexuality is I I really don't care that
he's gay I mean you shouldn't be groping
people well I mean unless they give you
consent I mean if someone gives you
consent you know feel away whatever you
want to do
but again I am not surprised that and I
don't know if you've ever watched Clips
with match lamp or listen to him talk
but it's kind of a lady G Lindsey Graham
situation uh the same time it's
unfortunate that these Republicans live
in a society that they created right
that they Christian Evangelical right
that they they can't believe who they
are and that is a sad reality that they
have constructed and they have put
themselves in that box and at the end of
the day then they take it out on
somebody else and say you don't have
these rights you can't be this person
you can't do this thing you can't
practice that thing whatever it might be
so that they can feel in control right
again these are the same people the same
people that are now voting on the house
floor to get control they are terrorists
domestic terrorists trying to control
through their fascist authoritarian
views
who are idolizing you know Victor Orban
on the CPAC stage right bringing it back
to CPAC here well that's that's funny
that you say that that they're domestic
terrorists because Matt schlapp
organizes CPAC and he in his
organization they put up on the big band
or on the Jumbotron we are all domestic
terrorists I mean we'll play out here
I'll find the clip so we can play it so
people know what we're talking about
it I mean it's a real thing and we're
gonna we're gonna go to bonehead of the
week here but uh so find that uh as I go
back to the house floor let me um go
back to the house floor for a second
here and show you
um and I'm gonna have to take a a quick
we'll take a quick break we'll watch the
house floor we'll take a quick break and
then we'll come back with bone in the
week but uh you see uh Hearn has three
Jordan has four yeah which is officially
that Kevin McCarthy is has well we also
again we also knew that Kevin Kevin
McCarthy is not going to get what does
chip boys saying
uh McCarthy yeah
look these
any three of these people
uh McCarthy her now that is significant
though
that is significant that chip Roy has
changed his vote
to McCarthy that's synonymous real yeah
but it also doesn't even matter because
here's the thing you've got
17 to 20 some odd domestic terrorists
out there that are trying to get their
own deal negotiated because at the end
of the day they're looking at themselves
and say look I'm gonna get mine that's
what they care about they don't care
about their constituents they don't care
about the voters who put them in they
don't care about the people that they
promise to do certain things like I
don't know govern legislate actually
represent them because at the end of the
day they're going to say how do I get
mine how do I better my position how do
I make sure that I have more power than
when I walked in how do I guarantee I
have power even before I'm ever even
sworn in
as a representative elect as someone who
just was was uh
uh won my re-election you know these
people don't care they are
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists see that's what I'm saying
they're all domestic terrorists there it
is and again they tried to be this
tongue-in-cheek ironic koi funny type of
it's all a joke kind of thing
but
I mean I I have a what was that coming
out of these top 10 moments from
Republicans like just the the Terrible
Things they've done and how it will
spread into 2023 and this made the cut
this and CPAC Victor Orban and we are
domestic terrorists these people try to
think they're being clever but at the
end of the day they're actually just
being idiots that are exposing their
true position they're saying the quiet
part out loud this whole time we've
we've called them domestic terrorists
and they're like oh this is gonna be
real funny oh man this joke is going to
be so good well here's the thing they
might have thought it was a joke but it
really wasn't I mean it's just them
being
truthful right
I'm gonna I'm gonna pull up the house
floor here
um and uh I'm gonna let you uh do some
commentating here of the house floor uh
while they while they vote I'll be I'll
be I'll be right back be right back
soon
Jeffries
Sherman
all right let's see what's going on here
all right so as predicted I'm going to
change my board and go 0 and 13 because
we know this is going to a 13th vote and
McCarthy will not get the money I mean
the other thing I want to point out is
how quickly
they abandoned Byron Donald's if we
remember two days ago they were throwing
out Byron Donald's as hey look we also
have a black representative that could
be a speaker of the house and everyone
tried to use that as fodder and fuel to
say oh we're not racist you know it's
the classic like oh my I have a you know
a friend that's also black kind of thing
and that is what the Republican party is
trying to do Corey Bush was so on the
nose that she called it out and then had
a bunch of Republicans and other white
dudes mediocre white men that all look
the same on the house floor oh okay so
this is actually development Sparks has
now voted for McCarthy she has moved
from present which means that she
potentially now got some some deal that
was made in the back so she has shifted
from present to McCarthy and that has
been
Over The Last Stand let's see she's been
voting present since day two so four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
votes she has voted present and now is
officially shifted over but back to
Byron Donald's the thing that we see
here is that they quickly abandoned
after yesterday they had abandoned Byron
Donald as a legitimate quote-unquote
legitimate candidate that they propped
him up to be Corey Bush got a lot of
flack for it for calling out that he was
just a prop and if they really did
believe this in that that Byron Donald
uh was an actual candidate they would
have stuck with him and supported him
like their Democrats have done with the
game Jeffries but Republicans are just
trying to prove they're not racist by
eventually abandoning their only black
candidate that they put forward Sykes uh
Tony there was a bit of a development
while you were gone yeah uh
we have now moved away from
um McCarthy from uh Victoria Sparks the
representative from Indiana who has been
voting present she has a shiftly
officially shifted her vote to McCarthy
which means some deal was made in the
background last night Mississippi yeah
well before this vote this this is
probably this chip Roy deal right
because we noticed chip Roy moved his
vote to McCarthy now McCarthy probably
won't have this he'll probably have less
votes today because there's three
members of the Republican caucus that
are missing today and again I want to
remind everyone this is a name vote so
they have to be present on the floor to
name vote they can't vote by proxy or
anything like that which is a thing on
the house floor but
and this right you can you can vote
digitally if you want to uh vote to
adjourn right but you can't you can't
physically right you have to be
physically present for a name vote right
where you're giving a name so uh and I
believe it's three it's three members
yeah I thought of that conference I
thought it was It was supposed before
but someone flew back in uh to
Washington I would have I honestly would
have laughed so hard if they miscounted
and like we're totally fine and then
like the sixth vote was somebody was
gone right but but here's the thing as
long as um uh there is just a few
holdouts right he's still not going to
get through so we are not going to have
a speaker today it will likely be
sometime next week if it is McCarthy um
if it's not McCarthy it will probably be
Beyond next week yeah McCarthy
Vargas so um I I think we should go
ahead and do just do bonehead of the
week okay because it kind of plays into
uh exactly what we're right about here
so uh we're gonna do this let's go to a
break
when we come back
we'll do bonehead
of the week
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
the vote is still happening on the house
floor the 12th vote even though Evan
McCarthy is in a position where he will
not reach enough votes to become the
Speaker of the House
and I doubt he's gonna reach that
threshold today anyhow the question is
how long will Democrats force them to
vote but we are at bonehead of the week
it's Friday we're in the second hour of
the show and boy uh do we have one
special bonehead this week but there's a
few others yeah yeah there's a view
again I've already put uh Owen 13
because I predict
Kevin McCarthy will lose the next vote
uh right I I think
they'll
the Democrats I think they'll Force the
Republicans to take at least four or
five votes today because yesterday they
did five votes right I think it'll be
four or five it could be three like it
was the first couple days right but I
think they're gonna force them to go
into the weekend and maybe adjourn till
Monday
um to to force them to four or five
votes so I would expect he's gonna go
well that would make him 16-0
yeah yeah I mean it's a clear knockout
like I I I honestly wish there was a way
or you know there was some kind of bylaw
or something in in the actual rules of
the vote that at their certain point if
you're like okay if this person gets the
majority
the simple majority the simple majority
again and again and again like at a
certain point like all right look we'll
call it at 50 guys like we need to we
need to really resolve this
I really wish there was a way for them
to just have that because
what we're doing right now is we are
holding America hostage
by these domestic terrorists trying to
get their they're trying to get theirs
right they're trying to win in whatever
way
by holding
Kevin McCarthy's balls hostage you know
I'm what
you're watching I'm watching the house
floor here and um Matt gatz and Paul
goes are now having a conversation so
you talk about domestic terrorists um
whoa McCarthy has 211. yeah again I I'm
I'm telling you
um this deal with chip and and uh Paul
gozar just voted for McCarthy yep 212.
now again this uh his column is moving
up which is an indication that this deal
for the rules committee with chip Roy
has been made
um the problem is
that they have not they do not have the
members to get him to 218 right
um so now rather they'll they'll get
there today I doubt it because again
they have three members missing and I
believe it's three I'd have to check the
reporting to be sure but yeah there are
seven votes remaining but if if there
are three or eight votes remaining right
now based on my account
which means that there's five boats
actually remaining
so we will see if he reaches that but
let's do this while we're waiting for
the next vote
to commence on the house floor where he
would go oh and 13 because he's already
lost a 12th vote let's go to bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week
boy Gabe Sanchez do we have one of the
biggest boneheads that we've experienced
at you know what actually they're all
pretty here's here's our contestants
this week representative Kevin McCarthy
he's trying desperately uh to just hit
the his name on the door of the speaker
of the house he is uh floundering
he is barely afloat he just he's just uh
officially lost well not officially but
unofficially lost the 12th vote on the
house floor he does not have the votes
here uh to get over or Reach the the
number of 218. is that um
right now there's three for uh Kevin
Hearn and four for Jim Jordan if you can
imagine Jim Jordan has made his way back
on the house Speaker list but we also
have Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green it's it's um not not surprising
that almost all of our boneheads this
week even the alpha guck
um and the dishonorable mention that
dishonorable mention isn't
a House member but it's part of the
house drama this week but I think the
dishonorable mention uh I think it's
good to have him here because it is the
second anniversary of the violent
Insurrection on January 6th so when we
get to the dishonorable mention you'll
know why right he probably made that
list but let's start off
with Lauren Bobo bobert the clown why
did she make our list other than uh the
drama that's been going on the house
floor is there something specific that
we wanted to put her on bone end of the
week uh yeah so she did a little bit of
a a press tour a media tour uh if you'll
call it that went on to different shows
she was on Sean Hannity which was Oh
What a great clip she was on the 11th
Hour which I don't know if I agree with
them giving her the air time as a Nazi
sympathizing insurrectionist election
denying just terrible person
but uh they did so but the reason the
main reason is it all is every one of
these people are rooted in this
infighting there's this infighting
that's happening behind the scenes but
they have now made it a public
uh a a public viewing for everyone us as
the as the public as the audience on
C-Span on Twitter on the internet on on
news stations to watch this fighting
unfold before our very eyes and really
show that this party is a bunch of
incompetent uh non-legislating uh
domestic terrorists boneheads boneheads
translation boneheads right you know the
funny part is that Kevin McCarthy moved
all his [ __ ] into the speaker's office
oh yeah um before the vote started so
which was kind of presumptive but also
none of these members have been sworn in
so there's actually no members of
Congress we don't have a congress as of
right now there's not 118 Congress
because none of them been sworn in
because we don't have a speaker to swear
the [ __ ] in yeah but also this
clip here I figured might be a good
representation of how bone-headed bobert
is
um this is a very quick clip I think she
posted it on her social media yeah she
was very proud about this oh yes now
this is uh they're taking the mags the
metal detectors
um out of the capital now I don't I'm
not quite sure how they could do this
yet since they're not actually
officially in power but there's a lot of
presumption this week about their power
so here's Lauren bobert talking about um
the security guards here removing the
metal detectors when I arrived
today they are being removed and we are
turning Pelosi's house back into the
people's house now
um if you see she's saying it real fast
because they're trying to like get out
of the way dude
you know like they're trying to move it
as she's trying to get her like two
cents in and meanwhile again like all
things Lauren bobert is in the way she's
in the way of somebody trying to do
their job and if this is not a perfect
representation for who Lauren bobert is
by removing things that were meant to
protect people in this [ __ ] building
because it's something that literally
happened two years ago to this day right
there were 1776 the speaker has left the
you know the the house or the chambers
or whatever like Lauren bobert is
someone who constantly gets in people's
way as a as a person who does not
actually add any value she put glasses
on she gave people a bunch of uh
diarrhea-inducing pork sliders and then
walks into the office as if she actually
has something to contribute and this
week we really saw her show that she has
nothing at all to ever contribute to the
American people when it comes to
representing their voice she talks about
the house of the people this is House of
bobert that's what she wants and she
probably thinks that the house of
something has to do with like the house
of dragons or the [ __ ] The Game of
Thrones like that's what she probably
really thinks that she wanted to be we
see chip Roy here on the house floor um
and it looks like a deal has been struck
with chip Roy because he turned I also
have news that Andrew Clyde the tourist
visit oh yeah [ __ ] box he has also
flipped to McCarthy so McCarthy has
gotten to 214 this is the largest vote
he's actually received in his conference
so far right um now the largest one was
earlier this week with 203 right so so
he's gained 11 votes here even if three
members are not on the uh on the house
floor so it appears that Kevin McCarthy
still will not be able to reach the 218
threshold but it is moving in his
Direction now we're four days into this
this is the 12th vote that he'll fail to
reach speaker but it is moving in his
Direction now as opposed to the way it
was moving I will be curious to see how
long it takes Matt Gates and Marjorie
Taylor green or no sorry Matt Gates and
Lauren bobert uh because because Kevin
McCarthy has already bought Marjorie
Taylor green right he's already promised
her to help release the j6
insurrectionist or the j6 Patriots or
whatever the [ __ ] they're called uh
they're all domestic terrorists I mean
they said it themselves we are domestic
terrorists the Republican party has said
it again and again and again uh and they
even played a clip for us right at CPAC
but I will be curious to see how long it
takes Lauren uh Lauren bobert and Matt
gates to flip and go pro McCarthy
because they have been very adamant
they've tried to evict him from the
office
I actually think those two will stay in
the non-mccarthy column until the very
end now speaking of Marjorie Taylor
Greene Lauren bobert we had Marjorie
Taylor green on the list as well now
there's several reasons but I actually
have
um a clip here I have a clip of of
Marjorie Taylor green talking about
Lauren bobert uh this is within the last
hour I believe maybe I don't know I'm
not sure I'm not sure what is time you
know it's uh
whoosh so let's listen to Marjorie
Taylor green talk about Lauren bobert
I think the American people no matter
how you vote are sick and tired of drama
and this is nothing but drama we're
we're on multiple days now with multiple
candidates from this group so I'm not
sure how Lauren bobert on one hand can
demand so much out of Kevin McCarthy but
then demand nothing out of someone else
and be willing to vote for them to be
speaker that's not serious
um I don't think that's leadership and I
really see it as more obstruction than
progress
oh boy so from the queen of drama
Marjorie tether Green from the horse's
mouth herself yeah
yeah the idea that she can say oh I'm
not up for this drama these guys are a
bunch of drama inducing people they want
drama uh this is we have to do our job
I also I'm pretty sure that reporters
from CNN so the fact that she's taking
an interview with CNN shows you how
desperate
that these Republicans are they're
taking interviews wherever they can go
because they've I think they've pretty
much
like tarnished any reputation on the
right-wing media shows to bash each
other now they have to go on anything
that is left of right
to bash these people again which only
makes for good entertainment I mean
Democrats are bringing in backs of
popcorn this week so
Democrats will and let's just point this
out Democrats will do everything they
can to actually work and help the
American people right we've already got
Senate in session they've already done
their stuff they've already got that
[ __ ] under control
the house is where we see this
obstruction of justice right this
obstruction of legislation we'll call it
but when you look at it the Democrats
are going to be the only ones who are
trying to get things done right if you
can look at this 2022 in comparison to
now it's going to be the same they're
going to continue to own the libs and
fight each other and hold each other
back while Democrats actually fight to
help the American people and it's going
to be a very black and white like day
and night contrast that the American
people can see going into the 2024
election this is going to be an example
that I'm sure people are already
constructing ads to show how the people
haven't even been sworn in yet and
they're already destroying
the party and destroying the ability to
actually help Americans now this
infighting that's happening between
Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor green
this isn't the only infighting with
Marjorie Taylor green and why she made
the bone out of the way the bonehead of
the week uh list this week uh Ali
Alexander now it's fitting that we are
showing this on the second anniversary
today is January 6th it is fitting that
I'm showing this video for one of our
bonehead contestants Marjorie Taylor
green where Ali Alexander is actually
saying in this clip that he has evidence
that she's committed crime apparently
um so now he he calls her a lot of
things in this clip he bust out all the
words that you're not supposed to call
someone but you know let's listen I will
not suffer this harlot
I will not be taught vows and loyalty
commitment
from a [ __ ]
you have got me mistaken for some damn
fool and a fool Ollie Alexander has
never been called
I've called him in the coming days I'm
going to reveal that Marjorie Taylor
Green in my summation and the summation
of lawyers committed a crime
hmm that crime is going to be handed to
the state of Georgia the state of
Georgia will decide whether they
adjudicate that crime or not
the house Ethics Committee
and house rules must expel Marjorie
Taylor green when this evidence comes to
light
hoe go home I am done with you damn you
are lukewarm I am spitting you out of my
mouth you played me and no more
so apparently George Santos is not the
only one with Marjorie Taylor Green in
his mouth Ali Alexander is spitting her
out what's funny about this clip in
unrelated news the FBI has um increased
their reward this is unrelated totally
unrelated unrelated I don't know why
you're bringing this I have no idea the
FBI has increased their reward to 500
000 for any information leading to the
pipe bomber I just want to just want to
throw that in there so Marjorie Taylor
green making the bonehead of the week
list and Ali Alexander absolutely
destroying her for whatever I don't I'm
not sure what he's alleging here but
and I why are they enemies now they once
we're friends I don't know look they're
all if you look at everyone that was
there right you had a on on January 6
also at Georgia too right there was uh
Ali Alexander Alex Jones Nick Fuentes
you're talking about the state capitol
right the state capital of Georgia they
were there inside the state capitol but
these are also people that were you know
present and active on January 6th in
terms I mean like the many players that
we learned last year uh from the January
6th hearings of you know you had Oath
Keepers proud boys Alex Jones Nick
Fuentes Ali Alexander you know you had
uh Santos there I'm sure he was I'm sure
George Santos was I'm sure at the end of
the day George Santo say yes I planned
I plan January 6th yeah
he will he's the architect he's the
architect I I have this probably he's
probably a lawyer too I don't know maybe
who knows but I honestly think that uh I
was I joked yesterday and I said this
vote is taking so long
that George Santos will be arrested
before he's ever sworn in and I'm
totally for that I'm not mad at all well
you know yesterday when I was on the air
with Jordy and Brett my zealous at the
Midas touch network of their coverage of
the house floor vote I said George
Santos is not some outlier in the
Republican party no not at all the the
only difference between George Santos
and other Republicans like Marjorie
Taylor green is George Santos lies about
all the Republican lies like he's like
oh I like that one I like that one I
like that one you know what I like that
one too so I'm just gonna do all the
lies not just a few of them
right most Republicans pick you know
four or five lies about themselves and
they continue to tell those lies about
themselves George Santos picks all the
Republican lies and says that about
himself the Republicans are even like
wait that's not that's not a thing no no
that's not don't say that don't don't
say that man
but George Santos can't help himself
right he had a tumor his mom died 47
times uh no no no no I think we're I
think we're up to 48 to 49. oh okay all
right yeah yeah you know the guy had a
business that got an injection of money
from questionable sources that didn't
have income before that he said he was
he worked at different
um uh Investment Banking firms on Wall
Street but then it turns out that he had
just like helped negotiate some deal you
know if you go to their website it's it
looks like it was built in like uh
geocities uh if you if you look at what
he said he said oh my grandmother was in
the hall like was uh
uh was in the Holocaust I can't remember
if he if if
they said that she survived or not I
don't remember that it's hard to
remember every single one but he's
Jewish you know and it's like oh God
jeez man well here is here is Marjorie
Taylor green one of our contestants
rabona of the week
um with George Santos last week's
contestant yeah let's let's watch
laughs
it's funny to watch those two
um
have have a great moment on the floor of
the house the only one willing to talk
to him
um even Matt gatz was not willing to
talk to him speaking of Matt Getz he's
our Alpha cuck of the week why
why say you
Dave Sanchez is Matt gatz our Alpha cook
of the week what did he cook or well he
uh you know other than voting for Jim
Jordan and nominating Jim Jordan uh we
found that he
voted
for Donald Trump and uh nominated Donald
Trump can you pull me the clip of him
promising yeah to nominate Trump because
I think this is important
um this is very important to go back
and to get a historical record
of Matt gatz promising to nominate Trump
on the house floor because yesterday we
watched two different things that Matt
Getz did for Donald Trump
um but before we do that I want to show
you this clip here
of Matt gatz promising to resign
if Democrats form a coalition around
a uh more of a like a moderate
Republican I think is the idea
are you going to be okay Congressman
will you be okay then if there's
ultimately a deal struck with moderate
Democrats that give Democrats kind of
co-control of the Committees you're fine
with that no absolutely not that that
will not happen there are two people
scenarios here no that listen I'm on the
floor Laura these 212 Democrats are
going to vote for Hakeem Jeffries every
single time he is a historic candidate
for them they are not going to cleave
off under any circumstance I assure you
that if Democrats join up to elect a
moderate Republican I will resign from
the House of Representatives that is how
certain I am I can assure your viewers
that won't happen again it makes me want
Democrats to get behind right some I
mean I don't want them to leave Akeem
Jeffries
um but if he's willing to resign I don't
know maybe May maybe they should just
consider that I mean it's a possibility
now I want to know you know if
if Kevin McCarthy I mean seeing that the
votes are trending his way on his side
right if he can get all of them we'll
see but if Kevin McCarthy becomes
speaker of the house I would be curious
if Matt Gates also will fulfill that
promise he just made and be like yeah
this is close enough I will resign I
mean like here's the thing all of these
guys make promises
except though Matt Gates did make a
promise here
he's a man of his word now this is March
27th of last year yeah March 27 2022
where he's at a trump Nazi rally excuse
me a trump rally and he makes a promise
let's listen there is no greater country
than America
there is no greater president than
Donald J Trump
[Music]
and if you don't mind me saying so there
is not a better member of Congress than
Marjorie Taylor Greene wow these
statements have aged so well the ability
to fire Nancy Pelosi take back the
majority impeach
for speaker of the United States House
of Representatives
so there's the um the funny thing is he
wasn't able to fire her because she
resigned and handed it over and said
Hakeem Jeffries is now the Next
Generation to take forward the gavel
Andy just pointed out that they're not
going to cleave away from him right
and uh marjor Taylor green turns out
there are better
representatives in in Congress than her
uh and there are better presidents than
you know the [ __ ] bag Donald Trump
well it just it just feels like it's not
that hard yeah I mean like when when the
bar is on the floor like it's literally
touching the ground and rolling down the
street
you're like ah okay I mean anything's
better than this right anything is
possible better
um
but it really shows you that from March
27th I mean that's uh
uh uh almost what is it set eight months
or so right
we're talking no yeah no yeah eight
months eight months because April
uh or nine months I guess now
technically but whatever uh but you look
at that who's who's counting I don't
know time anymore guys I don't know
what's going on but what I can tell you
is that so much has aged so well in in
less than a year from last March to now
January 6th the two-year anniversary of
the Insurrection at the Capitol
well here is Matt gatz nominating Donald
Trump
on the floor of the house for the 11th
ballot this was the final ballot
yesterday now before they adjourned
but if you notice I had to make sure
this was the correct clip because do you
notice behind him what is missing
everyone anymore almost looks like he
was in this room alone when he did this
I mean really I mean it looks like it
looks like how if you were to watch
C-SPAN it looks like it how it normally
does people don't really come in they
vote by proxy they don't vote they're
out of the office whatever
but yeah this is one of the [ __ ] from
the Republicans
um yesterday when they would take the
microphone it's like oh we have to do
our job this is ridiculous that we have
to do our job we can't believe that we
were expected to do work this is re this
is absolutely asinine that we would have
to do work but here is Matt Getz
fulfilling his promise yeah to nominate
he kept good with with uh with Don the
Donald yeah so here he is nominating the
Cheeto dusk q and I let's listen
if it will load
um
for crying out here we go here we go no
no nothing all right so you're gonna
have to mime it out for us really show
us how he cut for Donald Trump yeah I I
think I think I can make this work all
right let's see if I can make this work
let's try it again here we go Matt gatz
nominating Donald I also care deeply
about President Trump's focus on our
nation's veterans it seems for far too
long on the campaign Trail veterans were
disregarded forgotten about when we
would get elected to office their issues
rise and get Center Stage but we were
able to pass veterans uh accountability
measures we were able to actually get
people fired at the VA who weren't doing
their job what a great thing that would
be to extend and continue and to
continue to nourish president Trump
oriented our views on trade so that we
actually put the American people first
not foreign interests abroad or special
interests here at home
president Trump knew that we had to
confront China that China had already
engaged and get Chinese
he stood with our farmers and on foreign
policies
Jeffersonian democracy to build out of
sand and blood and Arab militias in the
Middle East matter of fact president
Trump I believe is the first president
of my lifetime that didn't start any new
Wars this is an issue that I know unites
some elements of the right and left for
the benefit of our communities
will the house be in order
this government for far too long has
been deeply corrupt this town has been
deeply correct I don't know if you
caught that but there was a member
saying he tried to overthrow our
government which is true again it's
fitting now here we are on January 6.
now this was yesterday uh but here we
are on January 6 and I'm playing this
clip and Matt Getz nominating the former
president United States who tried to
attempt to coup uh of our government and
overthrow our vote and trash our
Constitution and here he is on the floor
with the power of the Constitution
nominating Donald Trump as Speaker as
let's see let's let's listen to this
final word corrupt the way people get
leadership positions and chairmanships
and opportunities to be able to morally
Preen has been by accepting lobbyists
and special interest money and
redistributing that money as currency
for favors again
it really is [ __ ] now now
the reason why this is important that he
nominated Trump on the floor because he
voted for him first in the other
category and then in the next vote he
nominated him there the problem is and
and you put him in dishonorable mention
the problem is our dishonorable mention
of the week Donald Trump only received
one vote yeah he lost another election
well he watched two of them right well I
guess was it three I'm trying to
remember because he was voted he vote he
got a vote other yeah I think he I think
Matt Gantz voted for him other twice
right and then got the official so he
lost three times I mean from the very
beginning I caught like from the very
first suggestion that he was in an other
column I was like Donald Trump lost
another election like that's all you
needed to know for the rest of the day
even if he was officially nominated or
not he actually lost another election
which is hilarious uh you know and and I
think a huge uh ego dig at him despite
him trying to like post memes on true
social and be like ah you know
[Music]
um
he lost he lost multiple times yesterday
which means that he has lost multiple
elections outside of the popular vote in
2016. the popular vote and the electoral
vote in 2020. 2018 terms he lost 20.
exactly and the 2022 midterms he's like
oh well if they lose it it's their fault
if they win it's I get the credit and
not only that but then he also lost
States again and again and again when
legal teams tried to present any
evidence of voter fraud and and even
Trump judges said okay where's the proof
and then you got people like Rudy
Giuliani said well we don't got proof we
don't have evidence we have theories we
have theories we have these ideas
well here's here's a great idea Matt
Gantt stands up and votes for him here's
the moment where Matt Getz stood stands
up uh to give his name vote on the house
floor and a little name too says the
full name this is great let's listen
Gates
Trump Donald John Trump now again I want
to remind the audience his name is not
Gates you do not that that is not how
you spell Gates that is why I call him
gets and for the main reason why is I'm
intentionally saying his name the way he
doesn't want me to say it
um in hopes that one day he'll hear me
say it and it will piss him off for that
reason alone I continue to call him gats
not it's not Gates
um but there he is he's not he's voting
for Donald John Trump and the biggest
the biggest thing that I want to bring
up too about his claim is like oh you
know we are pro-veteran right we did all
these things why can't we do you know we
were able to do so much for you know as
a Republican party and stuff keep in
mind that one Trump is the person who on
Veterans Day said yeah let's uh let's
get those people out right he had a we
learned during the January 6 hearings I
think it was on day nine
uh wheel in October we learned that
Donald Trump on Veterans Day uh issued a
an order to to
um get get soldiers out of of
Afghanistan and I think it was Syria as
well
and didn't even didn't even keep in in
the thought or consideration of what the
next guy because he even admitted he's
like that's not my problem it's the next
guy's problem which is Joe Biden right
and we learned that memo and a different
uh military officials who came forward
and said oh yeah we told him not to do
that and we told him it would be a mess
but he's the president and he he went
forward to actually uh uh pull them out
of those areas without any plan without
any plan whatsoever and then you have
Republicans uh during the State of the
Union you've got Lauren bobert Margaret
Taylor green you know they're they're
having their you lie moment and trying
to say you don't care about the veterans
you don't care about the people from the
burn pits and then
two three days later they vote against
the health health care bill that would
have protected these veterans who had
actual health problems from these these
burn pits right so these Republicans do
not care about veterans they claim that
their Pro veteran pro-america pro-gun
all this [ __ ] but when it really
comes down to it in the legislation they
will vote again and again and again
against
the veterans of this country against the
people that they continue to say oh
thank you for your service we wouldn't
be here if it wasn't for you well that's
great and all but they don't do anything
to actually help the people that they
you know think
um and they just give them a big middle
finger and they say good luck at the VA
office which you know isn't great and
needs more resources and doesn't have
the actual uh
uh uh budget to actually help veterans
well the other reason why Donald John
Trump made it on the dishonorable
mention do you remember the news this
week it kind of got buried that um
seems as if Jack Smith defamation well
no no well that too but Jack Smith again
it's January 6th it's the second year of
the uh anniversary of the January 6 uh
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup the violent
Insurrection that the former president
Donald John
Jan Trump
um uh so incited at the ellipse now
there was some news from Kyle Cheney
this morning which I think is worth
mentioning in in this space and because
he says watch this space Kyle Chaney
says this in the past 48 Hours not one
not two but three secret grand jury
Court battles have landed before the
federal appeals court in D.C
do I know these are January 6 Trump
related question mark no
but they have Hallmarks of a similar
secret Court fight that occurred in
October
um so it looks like not only is Jack
Smith for Baron
to present charges before a grand jury
but there's been three secret grand jury
Court battles in the federal uh appeals
court in DC which is significant
um and you can go read I'm gonna I'm
gonna retweet this so you can go read
this thread because he talks about why
he thinks that this may be related
because of the Hallmarks that were in
the the October case but it appears Gabe
Sanchez
that Jack Smith is going to make his
move he's going to move on him like a
[ __ ] as someone might say someone
someone might say I don't know
oh so thank you Donald John
Trump Daniel Jan shrimp for being uh our
dishonorable mention of this week really
dishonorable mention of the century but
you know who's counting who's counting
actually we're counting we're counting
your vote
well and and the boats on the floor
there's all kinds of votes going on
there's a lot of votes a lot of votes I
would do want to say Kevin McCarthy
let's go back to the house floor it
looks like they haven't finalized the
12th vote here yeah but he's lost 12
times unofficially at this point yeah
yeah you're saying you're predicting
he's gonna go oh and 13 at least I think
he's gonna go
he's gonna go over 13. you could say you
could say
um
that uh I'm trying to remember did
yesterday did they did they vote to
adjourn and he lost that one well I mean
does it he almost lost the other day too
right right but here's the thing he did
win this week in one poll that is true
did win this week in one poll so
technically he is one in 12 because you
the audience voted Kevin McCarthy as
bonan of the week Kevin McCarthy you
have won bone of the week I don't even
know that it needs much explanation at
this point I mean honestly and you can
just type just type in McCarthy into
Google and you'll see all of the um well
I guess if you get enough losses it
counts as a win
you know enough time has gone by this
week which has felt like an eternity
just watching C-SPAN because it's the
same thing it's like Groundhog's Day
it's the same thing over and over again
he tries to win he loses he gets a bunch
of defense like people who are uh voting
against him he loses right like you you
see this over and over and over again uh
and Richie Torres has it right you know
he lost his 12th round we have we have
officially we have officially gone
beyond boxing metaphors now because we
are past the 12th round right this isn't
up for like a a vote from from the
officials or anything like that this is
now we're going into Extra Innings we
are we are now going into overtime this
isn't um
this is no longer boxing uh and there
won't be a knockout right uh based on
these numbers
here's the thing I want to point out uh
to the audience is that Kevin McCarthy
has got this is the the most votes he's
gotten for speaker of the house which is
12 14 in the 12th round now
why is this significant in his
boneheadedness
one
it took four days and 12 rounds to get
this close to 218. yeah that's the most
boneheaded part about this because
they've had weeks and weeks and weeks to
put these deals together now it appears
that the deal that was floated this
morning with chip Roy which I'm I'm
gonna try to see if I can find some
reporting on that
um they made a deal with Chip he's
apparently made a deal with chip Roy
uh for the rules committee chair so it
seems as if Chip Roy will become the
chairman of the rules committee and why
is that important the reason why that is
important is because that is where
almost all the speakers power lies now
if Kevin McCarthy that [ __ ] bonehead
gives all his power away in the rules
committee to a bunch of Q Anon
insurrectionists it is basically going
to strip away all the power that he as a
speaker will have on the floor of the
house in the rules
which is significant the reason why a
speaker of the house wants to have the
rules in their favor for controlling the
floor
and what business can be controlled in
the Committees and on the floor and the
subcommittees for that matter is so that
they can have coherency in their caucus
because they are in charge of the
majority and if they do not have
coherency in their caucus we see what
we've seen the last four days being
displayed where they can't even pick a
leader um here is a clip here of Chip
Roy voting for The bonehead of the week
just as you voted for bone end of the
week but he's voting for him as Speaker
which is more indication now that chip
Roy in this 12 in this 12th round has
made a deal for the chairman of the
rules committee let's listen Roy
[Applause]
again you hear the Applause from the
Republican caucus there and the reason
why is because
um again not just because chip Roy went
from the non-kevin McCarthy category two
Kevin McCarthy category but this is an
indication that there is a deal made for
the rules committee and ship Roy to be
the chairman of the rules committee is
there a good clip that we can pull to
show the folks who chip Roy really is
um let's see uh I wonder I wonder yeah
it's kind of hard to he's got so many of
them I'm sure but um
anyways yeah here we go here we go this
is from December 23rd this is who chip
really is
um if you want to know who he is we'll
play a little bit of this clip
help this body's not even gonna be here
and they're lying they're lying on forms
saying that they're voting by proxy for
covet and it's a lie and have this
body's gonna do it you know it and it's
destroying this country I'm not gonna
just sit here and roll over on this this
is going to continue the American people
precisely what's happening to them by
the people's house
expired the gentleman from Pennsylvania
reserves a gentleman from Massachusetts
is recognized okay so Chip Roy there and
during the 1.7 trillion dollar deal that
was made for the Omnibus package which
keeps inches the reason why they had to
pass that is because
they knew that these Republicans would
not be able to keep the government open
and so they had to get that the ominous
bill passed so they could get the
government open for some time to get
into this next Congress but here is Chip
Roy going to be the chair of the rules
committee and he's bitching about people
who have coveted or been exposed to
covet voting by proxy on the house floor
now I would imagine that the proxy vote
is going to go by the wayside or at
least be be scrutinized by chip Roy in
the rules committee if this deal stands
here's what I'll tell you
they won't be able to get [ __ ] done
because I don't know if you've ever
witnessed a boat on the house floor when
they're voting by proxy but almost every
single Republican votes by proxy oh yeah
chip Roy acting like it's only [ __ ]
Democrats voting by proxy well that
actually brings up but let me see if I
can find that clip but there's a clip of
Chip Roy
uh from this week complaining I mean he
was making his case I forget who was
making his case for I think it might
have been for Jordan
but he was trying to push the idea that
oh isn't it so great that we're here
everyone's here doing their job we're
we're working for the American people
this is this is what bipartisan debate
looks like this is democracy
now I'm not saying that you know chip
Roy avoids voting but to the point of
voting by proxy it does show that chip
Roy feels like he has better things to
do like he tells an aide or someone oh
hey look this is what my vote is they go
down the house floor they say this is
what the vote is voting by proxy he gets
someone else to do it right if he really
did care about what he was doing and his
job that he actually had then he would
be there himself but the only time that
it matters is when he's trying to
negotiate a deal so that he has more
power than when he walked into that
building
and this is what we've seen this week
um
I will try to try to find that well you
know I'm going to go back to the house
floor here for a second um to show this
um why you're looking for that clip and
we're running out of time here but the
um the house floor again
um
they're at the 13th vote officially
we've made the 12th moon official and
Kevin McCarthy is oh and twelve you're
predicted then you'll be Owen 13. did we
get a uh do we know if a Democrat was
missing I think one is supposed to be
missing okay all right yeah so one is
one Republican one Democrat
it's 214 211 3 and 4 gets me to 432
which means there's two remaining codes
that that may be possible there were
supposed to be three members of the
Republican
um uh caucus missing but it's possible
they stayed in Washington uh and one
returned from somewhere apparently uh
this early this morning to make sure the
boats were on the floor again to remind
the audience when these votes happen for
speaker of the house they are nameboats
so they cannot vote by proxy on a name
vote they have to be present on the
floor to make the name vote but the name
of the week for bone end of the week is
Kevin McCarthy because he cannot receive
he cannot receive enough votes this week
so in true bone and fashion keep Sanchez
let's give him his do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh Kevin McCarthy you are the Bonet of
the week thank you everyone for voting
for bonehead of the week this week every
single Friday you will find bonetta week
on the Tony Michaels podcast in a clip
on the Midas touch Network don't forget
to subscribe here on YouTube at the Tony
Michaels podcast you're on the mind is
touch Network come on over to the Tony
Michaels podcast we broadcast live every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube if you're on the minus touch
Network right now hit the Subscribe
button also download every single
episode of our podcast on Apple Spotify
and Google
make sure to follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod that's where you vote
Gabe Sanchez for bone net of the week on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod or again
you subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast go to the community tab the poll
will be there every single week on
Thursday and we will be here every
single week on Friday in the second hour
of the Tony Michaels podcast for bone
net of the week everyone if you're
watching the live show stick around we
have a few announcements that's been
your Edition bonehead of the week thanks
Kevin see ya
foreign
[Applause]
of the week
favorite oh my gosh I have to relay
refresh refresh you're getting the are
you still watching yeah because I feel
like C-SPAN this week has been doing
that a lot they're like wait are you
guys really watching us right
I I wonder what their ratings are like
this week so much traffic got to be
through the roof right
um so I want to make uh clear to the
folks out there Kevin McCarthy has in
the 12th vote receive the most amount of
votes that he's received so far this
week in the 12 votes in four days that
we've went through he got 214 in the
last round which chip Roy even Paul
gozar voted in Kevin McCarthy's column
which is indication that the deal that
everyone's talking about with chip Roy
to be the rule committee chair
um seems to be a real deal that is
happening
in the background now my guess is though
that they still will not be able to get
to the full 218 today
um because they are missing a member and
it does seem that they're still about a
half a dozen holdouts for Kevin McCarthy
which is the uh number that would put
him away from winning this so everyone
stay tuned if you if you need to you can
go to c-span.org or you can download the
seasman app on your phone and you can
watch the house War vote as it goes on
or you can head over to the ministers
Network they are covering it live as we
speak
but um you know have a great weekend be
safe yeah um and I I don't believe that
we will have a speaker but we'll see
we'll see we'll see when we come back
Monday pigs can fly maybe that happens
it happens it happens uh so have a great
weekend be safe and maybe just maybe we
won't have to watch C-SPAN on Monday
but if we do we do same time same place
on Monday Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon